يا مساء الخير عاملين ايه بعد 100 سنه من
دلوقتي 100 سنه ايه يمكن يعني ربي ربنا
يدي للجميع طوله العمر وحسن العمل بس يعني
احنا ستين سبعين صح الجسم هيروح وهيختفي
طب بلاش كده تعال تعال نفكر في حاجه تانيه
لو
جدك العاشر نفترض جدلا فكروا معي بس
لان انا عنوان الطوق النهارده
هي الاستوري بتاعتي بس انا جبتها من الاخر
وهرجع للاول لاني كنت ممكن اطلع واقول لك
قد ايه حاربنا وتحاربنا وقتلنا واتقتلنا
وتحديات والناس وقفت في طريقنا وما كانش
معنا فلوس نقعد على قهوه ونزلنا استلفنا
وتدايننا وبعد ما كسبنا خسرنا كل فلوسنا
وابهرك عادي جدا بص دي بقت حاجه عاديه جدا
ما فيش اي مخلوف في الدنيا وصل لاي نجاح
غير وعدى طبيعي يعني لازم هيعدي بالحاجات
دي كلها مش هتيجي هي كده ايه بسهوله يعني
طيب
الاسم مش احنا الاسم وخلاص هينتهي بعد ميه
200 300 سنه الاسم هيخلص طب الجسم
هيبلى لو جد السابع دلوقتي او التامن رجع
للحياه دلوقتي حالا ونسي طبعا يعني لو جد
السابع يبقى غالبا مواليد 1919 ثوره سعد
زغلول فلو رجع كان زمان بيلبسوا البدل
اللي هي بشورت دي فلو رجع ودخل ولبس بقى
بدله جميله من زارا
هيعرفني
هعرفه ما هو جسمه اهو وشكله اهو ما فيش حد
يعرف حد احنا كلنا كده انا واثق ان احنا
نعرف ستيف جوبز صح كلنا نعرفه بس انا ابني
واولادي جايين ممكن ما يعرفوش بس هيفضل
موجود بسبب
ابل التليفون بتاعه موجود في جيوبنا
وسماعاته في وداننا واللاب توب موجوده في
كل حته الراجل ده اختفى ومشي وساب الدنيا
بس لسه اسمه
هيخلص على فكره ده الفكر هو اللي هيتبقى
طب ده الفكر
الفكره بقى دي
بتتكون ازاي
انا واثق ولو اللي انا بقوله ده مش حقيقي
قولوا لي ان كلنا دلوقتي عندنا افكار ما
بين افكار طلعت للواقع وما بين افكار لسه
محبوسه ما طلعتش وما تحققتش مين اللي عنده
فكره لسه ما طلعتش
لسه ما خرجتش للنور طب مين اللي عنده فكره
طلعت واتعملت واتحققت
خليني اقول لك على سر
احنا نفسنا اصلا
قبل مثلا الخمسين ستين سنه كنا فكره في
عقول ابائنا وامهاتنا لحد مرتبط اتنين
مرتبطين
سميته الولد ايه
والبنت اخترت لها الاسم
من 20 سنه بالظبط من عشرين سنه بالزبط قلت
ان شاء الله لما هخلف ولد هسميه هارون
موجود في البيت دلوقتي
موجود
ايه ده ما هي فكره فكرت فيها بس في افكار
الطبيعه
بخلق ربنا ليك وبالقدرات اللي مديها لك
كده كده بتحصل
قبل سبع سنين قاعد مع
تلاته اصحابي على قهوه كده وجماعه عايزين
نعمل مشروع فقلت لهم بقول لكم نغسل
العربيات
فقلنا ماشي بس عايزين نعمل حاجه جديده
ننزل نغسل عربيات بدل ما الناس تروح
المغاسل نروح ايه نغسلها عند بيوتهم قلنا
خلاص احنا ايه هنجيب فناطيس ميه ونحطها
على عربيات نقل وبتاعه الموضوع صعب دخلنا
وبحثنا لقينا شويه علامات بتقول لنا لا في
حاجه اسمها مثلا غسيل من غير ميه
فطبعا جيت قلت لاكتر من حد كل اصحابي اللي
كانوا حواليا وعيلتي وقرايبي واغلبهم ايه
قال لك لا الواد ايه الواد ده تجنن العربي
من غير مايه يعني
ما يصحش يعني ما فيش الكلام ده فضلنا
نشتغل الفكره في دماغنا استمرينا يوم ورا
الثاني ورا الثالث ولا الرابع
شهر في الثاني في الثالث في الرابع
بقت واقع طب هي وقعت ليه
وقعت ليه يا جماعه عشان انا جامد خالص
والله هي كل قصه ان كان في ايمان ايمان
ربنا بيقول كده وكان حقا علينا نصر
المؤمنين انت مؤمن بالحاجه اللي انت
بتعملها طول ما في ايمان في نصر ما فيش
ايمان ما فيش اي حاجه خالص وانا عمال عايز
اثبت انا عايز اثبت عايز اثبت واشوف
واؤكد ان فعلا الفكره دي طريقه اتصال من
الاله بك مباشره
في مره كده
بقرا فجات قصه احد العلماء كان بيحكي قصه
سيدنا موسى عليه السلام فقال ايه قال ان
ربنا ربنا
اوحى لام موسى ان هي تعمل ايه يا ترضعه
على الاربعين فاذا خفت علي فايه
طب التواصل ده حصل ازاي
فكره
واوحينا الى ام موسى ان ارضعيه فاذا خفت
علي فالقيه في اليمن ايه ده
ايجابي عشان الحالات السلبيه كلها من
الشيطان مش من الرحمن يعني تاني حاجه
وقفت عند ايه تانيه بتقول ايه
وما كان لبشر احنا بشر يا جماعه صح كلنا
بشر كده ان يكلمه الله الا ايه
الا وحيا او من وراه حجاب زي سيدنا موسى
او يبعث رسولا ايه ده
انا ليه بقول لك كده انا عايز اخرج من هنا
عشان اقول لك ان ان انت عرفت الفاليو
بتاعه الفكره اللي بتدور في دماغ حضرتك
فارجوك ارجوك ما تسمحش لاي مخلوق في
الدنيا ان هو يسفه منك او يقلل من شانها
لان كده كده كده كده ده هيحصل زي ما انت
النهارده حتى لو انت مسافر نفسك تسافر بلد
معينه بتقابلك شويه مطبات المطار ده مطب
تقعد ساعه ساعتين والطياره كم ساعه بس انت
عشان شايف الايه البلد وعارف انت هتنزل
تعمل ايه فاللي بيحصل
بستحمل بعدي ده عمرك شفت حد قاعد في
المطار عمال يعيط ومتضايق ومخنوقه انا ليه
ما سافرتش هو عارف اوعيد في الطياره عمال
يبكي ليه هو عارف ما طبيعي الفكره اللي في
دماغك عشان تطلعها في النور عشان لما يجي
يوم من الايام انت انت تسيب الحياه واسمك
يسيبها وجسمك يسيبها يتبقى ايه بقى الفكره
لان هي دي اللي بتبني تخيل كده احنا
النهارده في تقريبا
مئات الافكار موجوده لو افكار دي حصلت
المجتمع هيبقى عامل ازاي
في وضعك المالي هيبقى عامل ازاي عائلتك
وزوجتك واهلك هيبقوا عاملين ازاي
اكيد
هو العالم يا جماعه لو في
ميت احمد زويل في مصر وميه مجدي يعقوب
وميت رحمه الله عليه مصطفى محمود وميت
ستيف جوبس وميت لهم ماسك وميت وميتو وميت
وميه هتبقى عامله ازاي
تقريبا كل الازمات بتحل بالايه
بالافكار لما فهمت الكلام ده
فرق معايا في حياتي بشكل كبير قوي قوي
واتوقع ان هو هيفرق مع حضرتك بس الاكشن
الاكشن الاكشن
مش هتستوي مش هتستوي اللي جات له فكره
وقعد
مستني حد كان لسه داخل كده صديق عزيز قال
لي عندي فكره بس ما عنديش امكانيات
اعملها على قدر الامكانات او الامكانيات
اللي معك طلع فاليو عشان الفكره تطلع
للنور محتاجه يبقى لها فاليو والفاليو دي
مش محتاجه تكون فاليو فرديه انانيه في
الاول ارجوك
عفوا تجنب الفاليوز الانانيه اللي انا
عايز الاغاني معه فلوس شوف الفكره قوتها
عامله ازاي وهتنفع عدد قد ايه من البشر
وكده كده الفلوس هتيجي كده كده وسال اي حد
عدى المليون والعشره مليون ونجحوا هيقول
لك القصه كلها ان انا بعمل حاجه بتنفع ولو
بصيت كده هو مارك اللي كانوا لسه عمال
يحسدوني شويه فتح كام بيت بسبب فيسبوك فكر
فيها في كم واحد عمل اونلاين ستور وكم
براند باع وكام براند كسب وكم شاب كسب
واليوتيوب اليوتيوب تقريبا كان اخر رقم مش
عارف حوالي 19 مليار السنه اللي فاتت موزع
نصهم بس على مين على الناس اللي بتقدم
كونتنت ايه ده يعني الفاون بتاع جوجل
وبتوع يوتيوب
ساعدوا ناس تكسب مليار هم يكسبوا عشره على
طول ده باقل حسابات الالهيه
الافكار او الفاليوز لو عندي فكره بحط لها
فاليوز جماعيه انا النهارده لما بخصل من
غير ميه مش هوفر ميه اسف مش مش هاهدر ميه
ومش هبهدل العربيات بميه واجعلنا من كل
شيء عايش بسبب
الفاليوز بتاخدك من
وانت مش واخد بالك ليه بقى لو في اتنين
عايزين يجيبوا عربيه محمد وسيد محمد هنا
وسيد هنا محمد عايز يجيب عربيه عشان يخرج
ويتفسح مع اصحابه ويتدلع وبتاع ويسافر
كويس وسيد عايز يجيب عربيه عشان زوجته ما
تتبهدلش في المواصلات والدته لو تعبت يروح
يوصلها واهله
ده محمد لو ركب مع واحد صاحبه اتفسحه
الفاليو راحت خلاص اخذها عشان فاليو ايه
انانيه انما الفاليو الجماعيه لا بتخلي
الدنيا معاك راحه في حته حلوه جدا
ابدا منين
حالا
حالا زي ما انت بص الشيطان دايما يخش لك
اول ما ربنا يديك فكره او يديك حاجه عشان
تقوم تعملها والله مديها لك من وسعك بس
انت بتروح لدرجه رقم سته وانت لسه ما
عملتش الدرجه رقم واحد انت لسه ما عملتش
الدرجه رقم واحد فكل قصه ابدا ابدا مفركش
ابدا منعكش والله كنا بنغسل عربيات في
الشارع لكن في مقر ولا كان في شركه ولا
كان في حسابات بنكيه ولا كان في عربيه ولا
كان في كنا بنقعد على القهوه قهوه اسمها
حبيبه تهدد دلوقتي في حسن المامون لما
عملوا التغييرات الاخيره دي
الله
ومنها الحمد لله مصنع وبيصدر لدول يخليك
كلهم وفي فرع ثاني في دوله قاعد هناك في
دول الخليج وفي فرع ثاني بيفتح في دوله
اوروبيه وبتصدر لكل العالم دلوقتي الحمد
لله المنتجات بتاعتنا يعني وتحت شعار صنع
في مصر يعني حق بلدنا علينا برضه فاللي
عايز اقوله ان ال ال كل ما هتجيلك الفكره
هتلاقي الشيطان داخل عمال يكسر داخل عمال
لا مش ليه ربك قال لك كده قالها لك بس انت
مش واخد بالك قال لك الشيطان ايه يعيدكم
الفقر اصل انا عايزك فقير عايز اكملش حاجه
تقول الفكره هيقول لك ما فيش يا عم انت
مدي الحفكه على قد رجليك ها يا عم عيش
عيشه مش كده مين مين جات له افكاره وسمع
الكلام ده في المجتمع او او مر بيه بشكل
كبير قوي هاي هاي انا جاي لكم من المستوى
الكلام ده فيك كله والله اللي مع ربنا
بيمشي على الميه على راي الفنان
طيب
اخر حاجه
في تمرين صغير اي حد عنده فكره اي حد عنده
فكره
حد عنده فكره اي فكره هنعمل تمرين مع بعض
صغير صغير بس هنعرف ازاي الفكره دي ممكن
ممكن تخرج للنور وممكن يبقى صوتها عالي
شويه او تبقى معروفه او مسموعه والناس
كلها بعد كده لما
هتسيب الحياه تبقى هي اللي مكمله وتبقى هي
الصدقه الجاريه اللي انت قاعد في التراب
وهي اللي عماله
عداد مش كده النبي عليه افضل الصلاه
والسلام قال لك ايه يموت ابن ادم وينقطع
عمله الا
منهم علم ينتفعوا به ما فكره
اسمك هينتهي جسمك هيبلى
اولادك عيلتك
جنسيتك كل ده هيروح واللي هيبقى هو ايه
فكرك فمن فضلك من فضلك حافظ على فكرك لان
ربنا لما هيحاسبك هيحاسبك على القوه
والقدره اللي هو اداها لك عشان تعمل حاجه
تنفع بها الامه بس انت
ما نفعتهاش كنت سعيد جدا ان انا معكم ربنا
يكرمكم ويحفظكم
وان شاء الله قريب جدا جدا جدا كلكم تبقوا
بتحكوا عن افكاركم اللي خرجت للنور شكرا
جدا لكم السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]